[Music]
it's safe to say that pretty much every
great counter-strike competitor has a
few clips that are
as the kids say suss shocks just
wants the engagements here he wants to
shoot people in the face and he will
close the distance if he has to
look at that one bullet fired one man
down
he make it take it down from the back
though
are you serious you can't do this no
it doesn't matter if you're shock see
fallen or the 16 year old who clapped
his cheeks in an online qualifier
if you're inhumanly talented at cs go
chances are
at some point you're going to conduct
yourself in a manner that appears well
inhuman so i assume there might be one
holding these far but probably just mid
flashing there he is could be mid he
heard that shot so he might peek into me
so i don't want to over swing
there's the peak now it could be one
more but he's probably not here if he is
he's outside a main which means he might
be peeking from squeak right here
if not a man to my left so i'm gonna
jiggle this yeah if he's right there
come back
from a different angle hold it he might
repeat in three
two kind of not fair
but with the exception of mr crisp clean
walks and those
sociopaths on the vac sucks subreddit
nobody actually thinks that the biggest
baddest names in counter-strike are all
secretly cheating
over the course of the franchise's
20-year history
innumerable prodigies pub stars
superstars and onliners have been
witch-hunted because of their propensity
for popping melons
and virtually all of them have lived
down their so-called
accusations except for
one meet robin flusha ronquist
a three-time major winner who in
addition to having one of the
biggest brains in cs go is one of the
game's
most controversial figures but not
because of anything he
said rather because of some very
dubious plays but this is flasher he's
the one with the m4 he's still fully set
up
he does catch a glimpse of one he gets
the tag he gets the kill oh how the hell
did he pull that off
20 points of health and seas is so close
and flush has almost a week to know this
this is such a
an unfair situation for flushing you
almost want to say because great
open bomb plan very hard to defuse back
there kiyoshima waiting to fight against
vw and that's going to leave crimson
flusher in an awful position
there there are obviously clips where
i've seen a flusha where it's just like
that's weird like that that's that
shouldn't happen
um that's kind of crazy
[Music]
what is he even looking at there let me
look at it again
in spite of flusha's countless titles
claims to innocence
and the effort it would have taken him
to cheat consistently on land for
years his catalog of fishy frags
is huge so huge that people can't help
but
question whether or not he cheated even
if they're terrified of the answer
i don't want to think that he was more
so because maybe i'm scared of what if
he was because what would that mean
for counter-strike so what is it that
makes flusha cs go's
sussist superstar ever and what weird
explanations have been presented in his
defense
and how is it that in spite of all the
hate he's managed to craft a cheeky
persona
around his notoriety it's been like this
for the most part of my
cs career i guess so i couldn't really
give up
so in order to understand how all of the
controversy surrounding flusha first
kicked off
we have to go all the way back to
dreamhack winter 2013
cs go's first ever major and the
cerebral swede's
breakout event flusher in a one-on-one
if he does this
that'll really cement his role as
probably the mvp of this whole
tournament he's already been playing
fantastically
but that would be truly something he's
behind the sandbags and they come for
him he gets the first kill now it's a
one on two and the bomb is ticking away
he's cl he's kind of stoned out here and
that's not good he has to go back and
get a head shot and they're waiting for
it to get right and slow the bomb is
being defused flush against the first
kill he sprays through they stop
defusing and it's a one-on-one flushes
out of bullets two left he goes down
deflaring but there's no time flusha did
it oh my god
it's gonna be eleven two four what
around
back then the soon-to-be-hated
rabble-rousers known as fnatic
were still a dark horse given that nip
spent a year making global offense of
their [ __ ]
and the french very games roster were
their only real
challenger it didn't feel like fnatic
should win the major
but as fate would have it they did it's
a one-on-two
all snyder in there and jd all they have
to do is just wait and buy time
and there it is they win it and look at
them
even khan jumping up one of the most uh
composed people i think encounter strike
complete celebration here's the thing
though
immediately after their impressive
performance at dreamhack
fanatic's results took a nosedive like
mibr after they lost coldzera nosedive
or just like mibr at any point
ever oh snap
anyway the point is that despite being
the defending champions heading into the
second major in katowice
fnatic looked like they were losing
their edge and then in a quarterfinal
that they would go on to
lose this happened but this is flusha
he's the one with the m4 he's still
fully set up he does catch a glimpse of
one he gets the tag he gets the kill
oh how the hell did he pull that off
watch that again
he does catch
when he gets the tag he gets the kill oh
how the hell did he pull that off
you you rush on i mean it's it's
it's uh
naturally this sent the community into a
bit of a hysteria
cheats had always been rampant and
counter-strike going way back to 1.6
but this wasn't at some two-bit land
cafe or an
online qualifier this was a goddamn
major
so i'd like to think he wasn't but i i
don't know i
genuinely don't think he was i think it
would be pretty hard to fathom
but then again i'm not a programmer and
you can hide stuff in the memory of a
mouse even in the history going back to
like 1.6
like some of the you know some of the
players that we caught cheating back
then or admitted to shooting back then
were were some of the you know some of
the top players at the time as well and
they just they just wanted that extra
edge um as
as crazy as that sounds so i mean i mean
you know anyone anyone can be a cheater
and that's that's like the reality of
the situation
by the summer of 2014 fnatic
boosted by the acquisition of
olofmeister and crims
found themselves resurging
see what i did there but during their
quarter-final match-up against
navi at esl one cologne the team found
themselves against the ropes
and it was then that flusha decided to
turn it on i'll leave it up to you to
decide what
it was i don't know it's i just know the
guy has an amazing game in mind for the
game
um with without any assistance
so yeah if he did it's it's tough to
tell for me those those the trigger lock
things those are confusing i remember
there's one on best two right
on the a-ramp that was a big one i
remember two looking at me like whoa
what the [ __ ]
and flushes almost a week to know this
this is such a an unfair situation for
flushing you almost want to say because
over the course of 2014 the community
became increasingly paranoid about the
possibility and
prevalence of hacking at cs go's highest
level of play
at first it felt as if things were being
blown a little out of proportion
it wasn't as if the entire professional
circuit was filled with cheaters
right he's out in the russian wilderness
just sniping
did emilio just get back banned
what what
oh god what what did we just see
i yeah i think this is a first like an
official match
and it's not like you know i looked over
and i was like oh he just got
disconnected or whatever maybe he's just
rebooting and then you see like vac
later that year the subject reached a
fever pitch
when a week before dreamhack winter 2014
a handful of tier 1 competitors were
wiped out
by the vacuning cs go's most scandalous
band wave to date
needless to say tensions were very high
going into the major and given that
fnatic had gone back to being arguably
the best roster in the world
the community started analyzing flusha's
gameplay like
never before
ah if that's not large jump
if that's not a large jump
i don't know what to say from what i've
heard there's a definitely possibility
especially before the gear check started
happening that
people could have done something and now
i'm just enabling all the i'm just
sprinkling
just gasoline on the vac sucks but yeah
hell even some of his peers started
drinking the haterade
the issue is that come 2015
flusha did anything but settle down not
only did he help fnatic secure
innumerable tournament wins including
two back-to-back majors but his clips
continued to be
stunningly suspicious great open bomb
part very hard to defuse back there
kiyoshima waiting to fight against jw
and that's gonna leave crimson flusher
in
can this guy as many times as he's done
go up in front of not only a giant
[ __ ] crowd and stadium
but hundreds of thousands of people
online and
the and play and compete against these
people that hurt his real life friends
for years and years and years
and cheat them out of hundreds of
thousands of dollars multiple times over
again
naturally the constant paranoia started
getting in the heads of his opponents
i was super hesitant always just because
the same thing happened to me in 1.6
i'm not gonna say i was convinced 100
either way because it's just like
it didn't first of all it didn't like
wasn't
worth it for me to spend all night
thinking about this i was just kind of
refreshing hmtv.org at the time seeing
like who's gonna get banned today
but like thinking about it more than
that was only gonna like get in my head
if i was gonna play against these guys
on lands i couldn't let it do that
needless to say flusha maintained his
innocence claiming that
one he lifted his mouse more than the
average player
and two that he was just that cerebral
that he just knew where everyone was i
just
feel like i can read every player so
well like i know what
they're doing just by the sound they're
making so
it doesn't really give me hard
hard time doing it i just always always
know what they're doing really it's been
like this for the most part of my
cs career i guess so i couldn't really
give up there was even this crazy story
that began
circulating about how flusha's playstyle
had developed while
playing on a computer that suffered
catastrophic
frame drops forcing him to predict where
his opponents would be
on the server it was just funny seeing
the way that that was that was
rationalized
and the idea that you know this this
trash can of a computer has
influenced so many of his decisions and
and how he's played the game at his
place now that he's selected
um to be this beast that he is um it's
just
it's just a ludicrous story and then
about midway through 2016
flusha and the rest of fnatic finally
began to cool off
now not only was the game becoming
increasingly competitive
but coincidentally valve had finally
started to buckle down on cs go's
unbearable cheater problem
and even though flusha looked to be
falling off a bit and his clips weren't
nearly as suspicious as before the
community couldn't help but scrutinize
his every waking frag
could spot out guardian but the cavalry
has arrived flamie is already on the
site and while caesars rotate around how
does flusha find him in the smoke like
that
see that's the thing flusha was
is one of the most absurdly big brained
bullies
ever to step foot on a counter-strike
server and in spite of all the suspicion
around his play
no one could deny that a lot of the time
the dude was just better and there's no
rush here for guardian guardian does not
have to play aggressively here flusha
are you kidding me this is so
intelligent no he no one's going to
check here he's waiting he wants to know
where star exists flusha is playing a
masterful game this is
the absolute highest level of counter
strike right now beautiful beautiful
round from flusher
he decides to get this he's going to
walk out guardian has no idea that's the
kill they've wasted so much time
flusha he may have just done it he's
going to go down and there's no time he
did it anyway
flusha was always i felt like so keyed
in to these little
nuances in the meta where he's like okay
i know where everyone's at and i know
this guy is gonna try to get testy with
me at b so he's just gonna do some weird
timing thing and he'll just
destroy the guy go back read it or
whatever the band read it is called they
would look at his timing and they would
focus only on him because look at the
second time i'm like yeah
just because you guys have never like
put this much thought into anything in
your life aside from find a sign
trying to find cheaters it doesn't mean
the guy is well hacking no matter how
many times flusha proclaimed his
innocence
the community refused to believe him and
so he opted to run with it instead
ingeniously dubbing himself senor vac
i can't can't get over the fact that his
truck says send novak it's
so ridiculous isn't it he just owns it
man he leaned into it
he was feeding the trolls in that sense
he was like yeah you guys are calling me
out fine i'll keep doing it too
and you know what i'll make it even more
obvious and let's see what are you guys
gonna do about it you know
i'm still gonna be over here winning i
don't care listen i'm not gonna [ __ ]
there's
some of those clips are obviously
sketchy some of those clips are
obviously weird
but again you can't do anything about it
and the best part is flush has handled
it i mean damn near
perfectly the way he's he's handled the
whole controversy the way he's leaned
into it with senor vac
like this he's he's done he's done such
a good job of turning it into like a
facet
of his persona in a facet of just
professional counter strike
to this day it isn't clear what to make
of flusha's
catalog of incriminating clips both in
terms of how questionable they are
and just how many of them there are
could flusha have cheated
it's possible did he barring
some kind of admission there's virtually
no way we'll
ever know if it happened he beat the
game like i don't know there's no other
way to do it
because you can't but go back now and
like retroactively you know enforce that
that justice on them and there's
i don't think there's any way to
retroactively go back and actually even
if we develop some like crazy ai system
you know one year down the road that
could 100
detect sheets i don't even know if
they'd be able to to go back and like
you know review a demo and detect it or
anything like that
what we do know is that after six years
of people swearing on their lives that
flusha is a dirty filthy cheater
there has never been a shred of hard
evidence to support that claim
is flusha hacking
i guess that's up to everyone else's
opinion and even though it's been a
little while since flusha produced a
truly fishy frag
he's still routinely making cs go fans
question
everything they thought was possible in
the game
however definitely spots him oh
not only does he spot him thank you very
much oh wow
no way no way
and not only that he's caused a full
rotation from ivy from rain and sort of
zika inside of z connector and flusha
gets one more kill on this let got the
whole map to play with
he's hoping that flusha can anchor this
position down but he has the option to
go back to a look at flusha go my god
this would be a harsh reset on 14 rounds
for fnatic
and that smoke is tantalizing
[Applause]
he's gonna clean out connector he
figures this out now this is interesting
because now it's return favor
nico's snuck around behind flusha
and he could actually spoil the whole
plan as sneaky as flusha was
oh my god it's all going according to
fan right now
14 seconds on the clock and flusher he's
counting it he's still hiding back there
that's one kill that devolves the
flasher an absolutely genius move
they finally take him but that is too
late they brought the fight
onto fnatic's playground and they took
all of their toys and sent them packing
yeah he's got a smoke that's about as
good as it gets no kip
off the smoke on the side trying to find
what oh sick
no scope does he get this dude tarik
alone
1v1 versus flusha
man flusha dancing around gotta spot him
and he gets it done
he has no nades though and guardians got
the angle here
unbelievable hits the head shot
regardless and now it's into the 1v1
caesar's holding close to the connector
will flush will be able to figure this
out
seems to have an idea of it that he
could be learning oh my god the whole
big headstock replacer lift it let's go
and honestly if you're gonna tear down a
three-time major champion
one of the clutches and most
accomplished competitors counter-strike
has
ever seen you're gonna have to do better
than a few head scratching clips
but of course flusha knows that and has
spent years
thumbing his nose accordingly we're
staying but
i've never used aimbot man i have both
hacks though
and look as crazy as it might sound
you gotta admit that there's something
kind of badass about that
the mystery around whether he cheated or
not is actually
i don't know i find it in a certain way
kind of kind of cool
i mean i know that's like insane to say
um
but i really like the way he's built
that legend around it whether you
like it or not senor vac
has ingrained himself into the very
fabric of counter-strike
he's a specter of death and uncertainty
whose deep dark dank dumpstrings
will forever aggravate and excite
his scene if it does come out you know
if he ever comes out you know a year
from now and admits to it or if he ever
gets caught for whatever reason then
there should be
massive consequences but until that
happens um
until that happens then you know let's
just enjoy the flusher ride because i've
been having a fun time with it and
i i love everything about it for the
moment until until it gets ruined i'm
i'm buckled in i'm ready i'm here for
the whole thing but flush up
a little bit more of elephant titus oh
finds the angle on to olaf and the info
on the other one surely not a 1v3 from
flusher
rain see you later
[Music]
see this [ __ ] like
i don't think